after dozens and dozens of accusations
ranging over a period of decades Bill
Cosby has been found guilty on three
counts of aggravated indecent assault
for drugging and sexually assaulting
Andrea constant 14 years ago he faces
potentially 30 years in prison I'll talk
more about that in a moment the three
counts were aggravated indecent assault
without the victims consent aggravated
indecent assault while the victim was
unconscious or unaware and while the
victim was intoxicated or drugged and
yes
Bill Cosby guilty on all three counts
now he potentially faces 10 years per
count which could be if served
sequentially thirty years in prison he
will probably get something less than
ten years for each count the three
sentences would be served concurrently
and they might even be suspended
sentences more than likely I would
expect somewhere from two to eight years
in prison most likely and a possible
suspended sentence with a long
probationary period is even possible and
right after the verdict prosecutors
asked for Cosby's bail to be revoked
saying this guy has a private plane he
is literally a flight risk and Cosby
reportedly stood up in the middle of the
court and yelled he doesn't have a plane
you [ __ ]
interesting bit of color from the
courtroom the judge decided not to
revoke bail but Cosby has to stay at one
of his homes he has many homes he has to
stay at one of his homes until
sentencing if he wants to go to another
one of the homes he needs to get himself
a GPS tracker and this story is very
interesting for a few different reasons
number one this was one of the catalysts
of the me2 movement which is now in full
swing and whether you like or dislike
that movement and there are people in
our audience with differing opinions on
that the Bill Cosby case was one of the
cases that was subsequently followed by
the Harvey Weinstein case and many
others that really got things moving so
retrospectively actually getting a
criminal conviction here is a really big
deal now I'm very interested in the idea
of whether this is any kind of justice
for all the alleged victims and
is a very interesting piece in the New
York Daily News where they spoke to
Robin Quivers the co-host of the Howard
Stern Show someone who was sexually
abused when she was younger and has
spoken out about it and she said she
doesn't really see this as a situation
that provides justice to all of Bill
Cosby's accusers and I tend to agree
Bill Cosby by and large got away with it
right he got away with it for decades by
all accounts it has been known within
Hollywood circles that Cosby was doing
this to countless women he got away with
it and he continued to do it to more and
more women as the years went on so yes
he's been found guilty he will serve
some kind of symbolic sentence a
sentence that could be a death sentence
for someone his age but at the same time
could end up being a suspended sentence
and probation and or home confinement
but there was a definite lack of justice
for a very long time and if I'm a victim
of Bill Cosby's from 30 years ago do I
see this verdict and the eventual
sentence which we still don't don't know
the details of do we see that as justice
for everything he allegedly did for me
the answer is clearly no and
particularly if he ends up not doing any
prison time I have a hard time seeing
this as actual justice and it will more
than likely although I guess you know
there could be another case brought
against him if there are others that
have not gone beyond the statute of
limitations I don't know that I really
see this as justice if I'm one of the
many accusers yeah there's only one
plaintiff on record here and there are
about 60 accusers but in the end does it
really matter especially if the guy is
as you know he's 80 years old he's
probably gonna spend the rest of his
life in prison so I think the outcome
would be the same yes there's a lack of
justice because he was able to get away
with it for all these years but I think
just having that one case and that one
sentence is enough it's May I mean are
you so there's a good chance he's not
gonna spend any time in project remember
I think that to say it's enough it's
enough given that he got this far in
life without ever having been convicted
previously but I think the real question
for me would be what what is the feeling
of those accusers from decades ago and
like
is strange right 25 years ago who would
have believed Cosby could potentially
die in prison and Donald Trump would be
President of the United States which is
why I say let's just focus on the 2018
midterms and not even think about 2020
at this point because really who the
hell knows right support for today's
show comes from ever quote America's
largest online marketplace for auto
insurance only 5% of drivers pay under
$50 a month for auto insurance
nationally but ever quote is helping to
change that with a proprietary matching
algorithm that helps you find the right
coverage at the right price and in fact
data shows that users who find their
auto insurance through ever quote save
an average of five hundred and thirty
six dollars per year no wonder over
300,000 shoppers use ever quotes
insurance matching services every day
take advantage of ever quotes
cutting-edge data and analytics and go
to every quote dot-com slash Pakman to
compare coverage options today